ja noch nie hat scheitern so viele
Chancen eröffnet ich beziehe mich
natürlich auf die
landesfassungsgerichts gerichtssprechung
gestern Wahlwiederholung in Berlin
Rot-Grün linke sind in Berlin
gescheitert wir erleben jeden Tag aufs
Neue dass
linke Politik linke Ideologen diese
Stadt ins Chaos äh stürzen ob wir über
mietendeckel reden der von
Bundesverfassungsgericht gekippt werden
musste ob es über Neubau Tätigkeiten
geht ob es darüber geht das Gerichte die
willkürliche ähm Sperrung von Straßen
für den Autoverkehr verhindern müssen ob
es das Bildungsdefizit in Berlin ist das
links grüne Märchen vom bullerbühnen
Berlin ist schon ziemlich abgebrannt und
Berlin ist mittlerweile ein Mahnmal wie
unkontrollierte linke Ideologen eine
Stadt ein Land kaputt machen können und
auf der anderen Seite sehen wir das
verwaltungschaos
du das primär aufgrund der organisierten
Verantwortungslosigkeit zwischen Land
und Bezirken hier stattfindet keiner ist
für irgendetwas verantwortlich alle
wollen mitreden niemand übernimmt am
Ende die Entscheidungskompetenz und das
ist nicht in den letzten Tagen oder
Wochen passiert sondern am Ende des
Tages haben alle Parteien die in den
letzten 30 Jahren in Berlin
Regierungsverantwortung übernommen haben
das ist die SPD das ist die linke und
das sind die Grünen aber auch die CDU
sich hier darauf ein ähm oder sich
darauf ausgeruht dass diese
statistikfunktional ist und dass man
hier nicht allzu viel Politik für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger machen muss ich
als gebürtiger Berliner bin es leid mich
für die Berliner Stadtpolitik
entschuldigen zu müssen mich dafür
schämen zu müssen wie die
Landesregierung hier agiert und früher
war es so dass man Sport ertragen musste
wenn man sagte man ist in Berlin
politisch aktiv mittlerweile so dass man
bedauert und damit dass man nur bedauern
hört dass es der Tiefpunkt den dieses
landesverfassungsgerichtsurteil
letztlich als Sinnbild jetzt auslöst und
deswegen ist der 12 Februar nächsten
Jahres eine Chance für ein wirklichen
Neustart in der Stadt und da müssen wir
glaube ich die die die Stadt
voranbringen wollen alle daran arbeiten
und glauben dann geht es mit der Stadt
auch wieder voran dann haben wir auch
wieder eine Hauptstadt auf die man stolz
sein kann ich glaube Herr Meier sind da
ganz viel Wahres gesagt nicht wunderlos
drei von zwei von den Parteien die hier
regieren sind Koalitionspartner ihre FDP
im Bund und so drastisch wie sie glaube
ich dieses Problem ja auch beschrieben
haben und so klar wie sie auch eine
Aussage waren muss man ehrlicherweise
sagen ähm ist es sehr offen schwingt er
glaube ich sehr viel mit wie eigentlich
es um die Ampel im Bund bestellt ist
weil sie damit zwei Parteien koalieren
mit denen sie eigentlich über überhaupt
nicht zusammenpassen da ich sie haben
das sehr gut beschrieben die Linkspartei
ist sicherlich in Berlin mächtiger als
sie es im Bundesgebiete ohne Frage aber
trotzdem haben sie es hier mit ähm SPD
Politiker und grünen Politik zu tun
unter anderem mit Frau Giffey die ja
sogar mal Bundesministerin gewesen ist
also sind genau die beiden Parteien die
sie hier attackieren mit der die FDP im
Bund regieren und mich wundert wenn ich
das auch so höre ja
bis vor kurzem Bundesministerin gewesen
das ist ja richtig aber deine Auszeit
genommen hat auf Steuerzahler Kosten um
ihren Wahlkampf hier in Berlin
vorzubereiten das ist ja alles richtig
aber ich glaube die Berliner die
Berliner Grünen auch Sympathien
teilweise für
klima-kleber sind noch mal ein bisschen
anderer Schlag als vielleicht die Grünen
hier in
baden-weltministerin genauso gesehen hat
alles alles richtig sagen ja nicht am
Anfang also sagen nicht dass die Ampel
ähm im Bund meine politische
wunschkonstellation ist wir arbeiten den
Umständen entsprechend gut zusammen es
ist ein steht drin aber wenn wir uns
Berlin ansehen und wir sehen uns ansehen
wie diese Stadt an die Wand gefahren
wurde dann muss man feststellen dass die
politische Verantwortung dazu stehe ich
unabhängig davon was auf der Bundesebene
an Koalition haben dass die politische
Verantwortung dafür bei SPD grün aber
auch linken und CDU liegt und damit
haben wir mit dem 12 februar die
Möglichkeit eines neu Startens und das
muss man nutzen das Problem liegt ja
daran die Umfragen zeigen ja schon es
wird wenig Veränderung geben lohnen sich
diese neue Wahlen jetzt überhaupt das
werden wir erstmal sehen ob ähm ob die
also zum einen Umfragen sind keine
Wahlergebnisse ist glaube ich so starke
FDP ich glaube eine starke FDP ich
glaube auch da daran dass ich die Union
auch in der Opposition in Berlin Stück
weit regeneriert hat so dass wir die
Möglichkeit haben eine Alternative
darzustellen am Ende des Tages wenn wir
glauben
fast 90 Tage vor einer Wahl das Wahlen
nichts ändern denn ist das ein
fatalistischer Ansatz der glaube ich uns
allen nichts bringen
viele Menschen das Denken des Tages ist
es jetzt die Aufgabe dass wir hier in
der Stadt gucken was ist alles schief
gegangen und was kann man besser machen
auf diesen Punkt von Frau Hermenau ein
der ist nämlich sehr spannend den sie
gerade gesagt haben also die
Wahlbeteiligungen sind ja schlecht es
war jetzt auch in Niedersachsen so das
ist in Osten schon länger so das hat
damit zu tun dass es viele Menschen gibt
die denken das Wahlen nichts mehr ändern
Wahlen sind ein vorschussvertrauen an
Politiker man entscheidet sich und denkt
die werden das schon ordentlich machen
so ungefähr läuft das ja im Kopf ab und
es gibt immer mehr Menschen die wirklich
eine weinende Kabine stehen überlegen oh
Gott verdammt was streiche ich denn
jetzt an nee und das wird immer
schwieriger und das hat damit zu tun
dass egal ob das jetzt CDU SPD linke
grüne oder FDP ist sie kriegen immer
dasselbe das ist wurscht was sie wählen
das ist glaube ich
wirklich nicht richtig na gut denn wir
können uns ja auch zum Beispiel beim
Thema Schule mal Vergleiche anschauen im
traditionell rot regierten Bremen ist
der Schulsystem katastrophal das
traditionell schwarz regierte Bayern
kommt komischerweise auf exzellen
ich habe nicht gedacht
ähm Werte wenn man das Thema Sachsen
beispielsweise erinner ich mich daran
dass eigentlich seitdem es gibt immer
ein ein CDU-Ministerpräsidenten das mag
durchaus etwas damit zu tun haben wie
Politik ist und wenn man sich in Berlin
anschaut dann macht er zumindest
Christoph mal den Eindruck als wenn er
etwas ändern wollte selbst wenn er mit
den roten und grünen aber ich glaube
dass das stimmt ist dann wäre es doch
eigentlich mal schlau dass wir uns
wieder mehr darauf konzentrieren dass
wir eine Föderation sind und dass wir
dann einfach den Bundesländern mehr
ihren eigenen Spielraum lassen und dann
bin ich aber auch dafür den
Länderfinanzausgleich runter zu fahren
und dann soll jedes Bundesland mal
zeigen was es drauf hat Berlin ist ein
interessanter Standort für Investoren
wenn es ordentlich gemanagt wird das ist
finde ich eine interessante
Herausforderung da könnte man viel
lernen berlin braucht möglicherweise
eine rot-grünes Modell das sage ich
jetzt ganz bewusst und ganz provokant
weil Berlin diese knapp 9 Milliarden und
9 Milliarden aus dem
Länderfinanzausgleich auch sehr sehr gut
gebrauchen kann der leben viele Menschen
sehr sehr gut muss man noch mal Berlin
mal sehen was eigentlich Berlin für eine
rollenden Land hat ihre
schaufensterfunktion also Mensch der
sagt ist der international es ist halt
die Stadt in Deutschland ja und es ist
halt auch kein Wort Standort mehr das
heißt für Leute schon seit langer Zeit
nicht mehr aber die Sache ist mit
welchen Geld dann wurde Berlin zu diesem
schönen Schaufenster gemacht wo wurde
das Geld erwirtschaftet für das schöne
Schaufenster
Berliner Finanzausgleich gar nicht mehr
existiert in der Form anders
dieser Stadt also von der Funktion her
also es gab glaube ich also so nach in
den 90ern hat Berlin dann sozusagen
diese diese Party Metropole gehabt jetzt
haben wir die nächste große Welle die
wieder das eventuell ändert und zwar ist
halt so dieses Gen kann oder
Transsexuellen und so weiter die sehen
sich in Berlin nicht nee na schon lange
nicht mehr die Zeit nicht vorbei
nicht bedroht und darum kommen
wahnsinnig viele Leute in die Stadt aber
das und das dann eine Stadt die
permanent am Tropf hängt die muss sich
überlegen wie komme ich von dem Tropf
los von dem finanzstropfen
überhaupt nichts zu tun
[Gelächter]
Bayern war die ersten Jahrzehnte
ebenfalls ein Radstadt war ein
Nimmerland aus dem damaligen
das Problem in Berlin ist doch das hier
Wirtschaft systematisch vertraut wird
dass die Probleme die diese Stadt hat
selber angesprochen sehen Sie denn den
Berliner Strauß der Strauß hat der den
Airbus geschafft also sehen Sie in
Berlin irgendwie wo man sagen kann ja da
kommen richtig losgehen mit der
Wirtschaft wir haben zum zum Beispiel
gerade auf auf Bundesebene den Weg frei
gemacht für ein
translationszentrum für gehen und
Zelltherapie in Berlin am Ende des Tages
können wir ja nicht den Arbeitsplätzen
der Vergangenheit und der Wirtschaft
nachhängen sollen müssen gucken was die
Entwicklung der Zukunft wir haben ich
will nicht auf auf einzelne Personen wir
haben nicht mehr irgendwie den Siemens
oder wie auch immer wir müssen gucken
dass wir aus den voraussetzen und die
diese Stadt hat das Beste an
industrieller an
Wertschöpfung für die nächsten
Jahrzehnte machen und da müssen wir mehr
in Forschung investieren dann müssen wir
unternehmen willkommen heißen da dürfen
wir nicht den Wohnungsbau so abwürgen
wie das in den letzten Jahren passiert
ist wir dürfen keine ideologischen
Experimente gegen den ähm Autoverkehr
machen wir dürfen nicht ähm Klima Kleber
bekommen heißen sondern wir müssen am
Ende des Tages ein Bild machen dass
diejenigen die Berlin interessant und
attraktiv finden hierher kommen hier
Geschäft machen wollen vier
Arbeitsplätze schaffen und damit dann
auch Wirtschafts wer ist denn das wir
wer ist denn das wieder wir sind die
Parteien die es ändern wollen die jetzt
zur Wahl angemessen ich glaube schon
dass es in der Stadt einen ganzen Menge
Leute geben gibt die die sich damit
nicht mehr abfinden wollen mit denen sie
das umsetzen können in Berlin
ist ich hoffe auch nach wie vor auf
Teile der SPD und ansonsten muss man
sagen dass all diejenigen die für diesen
Neustart zur Verfügung stehen wollen
willkommen sind und das ist ja genau das
was Sie auf der anderen Seite sagen
müssen erstmal in ihrem Thema vorhin
dass wir zum eine uns ehrlich machen
müssen dass wir sagen müssen was sind
die Probleme und wer will daran
mitarbeiten an der Lösung und das
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil und das
Desaster vor einem Jahr bei der Wahl ist
so gravierend dass wir jetzt eine
Situation haben dass wir die Probleme in
der Stadt wirklich reden können und dass
wir Lösungsansätze dafür zur Wahl
stellen können am 12 FE bruar und
deswegen bin ich gar nicht so passieren